man wacht auf und es ist krieg im
flächenmäßig größten land europas die
menschen in angst die welt bestürzt alle
diplomatischen bemühungen sind
gescheitert seit dem frühen morgen
greift russland also die ukraine an das
leben unzähliger menschen ist bedroht
durch angriffe mit raketen mit
kampfflugzeugen und militärhubschraubern
viele menschen spenden inzwischen blut
sie befürchten das schlimmste schon
rücken russische bodentruppen in irland
ein
wir schreiben den 24 februar
2022 und schon heute ist gewiss dass
dieser tag als rabenschwarzer tag in die
europäische geschichte eingehen wird und
damit willkommen zu diesem zdf spezial
fast 77 jahre nach ende des zweiten
weltkriegs wird also ein unabhängiger
staat von seinem nachbarn angegriffen ja
überfallen und das mit einer begründung
die ja noch dunklere zeiten erinnert in
seiner kriegs rede spricht wladimir
putin von einem akt der
selbstverteidigung die ukraine müsse
entmilitarisiert werden um russland
sicherheit zu gewährleisten sagte er was
das zu bedeuten hat und wie der westen
darauf reagiert das wollen wir
analysieren in diesem sport zdf spezial
mit dem wir auch die angekündigte
ansprache von bundeskanzler scholz
übertragen werden um halb sechs zunächst
aber ein blick auf den kriegsschauplatz
selbst gert anhalt fasst zusammen was an
bildern und informationen einigermaßen
verlässlich ist
wie ein unwetter am östlichen horizont
zieht der krieg hinter der stadt charkiw
auf 40 kilometer vor der russischen
grenze
ungläubig und verwirrt die reaktionen
der augenzeugen was war das wo kam das
heer
und bald befinden sich die bewohner der
millionenstadt mitten im krieg
das war der schlimmste sonnenaufgang
meines lebens erklärt die junge frau ich
wachte um 5 uhr auf weil geschossen
wurde rannte auf dem balkon und da wurde
mir klar das war kein feuerwerk
da stieg schon unweit von hartz iv eine
rauchsäule über dem luftwaffenstützpunkt
schuf auf den die russen gleich unter
feuer nahmen um die luftabwehr
auszuschalten
und selbst 800 kilometer westlich der
hauptstadt kiew begann der tag mit
sirenengeheul und der ukrainische
präsident sprach in einer offenbar
hastig aufgezeichneten smartphone
botschaft zum volk
explosionen werden aus vielen städten
der ukraine gemeldet wir führen hier mit
das kriegsrecht ein vor einer minute
habe ich mit präsident beiden gesprochen
die amerikaner bemühen sich um
internationale unterstützung wie drin
während von der krim her die ersten
militärkonvois richtung westen rollen
warten auf der seit 2014 besetzten
halbinsel noch weitere kilometerlangen
konvois auf den marschbefehl
ihre angriffe gelten nur militärischen
zielen behaupten die russischen
strategen aber die ersten bilder aus der
ost ukraine zeigen nicht nur zerstörte
infrastruktur
hierbei soll es sich um den flughafen
von mario pohl handeln sondern auch
getroffene wohnanlagen der ukrainische
verteidigungsminister rief alle
einsatzfähigen landsleute auf sich bei
der truppe zu melden
jeder der eine waffe halten kann soll
sich bei den streitkräften einfinden wir
haben das verfahren vereinfacht jedem
patrioten der seinen pass vorzeigt wird
ein gewehr ausgehändigt
schon morgens bricht in kiew der verkehr
zusammen als habe die ganze stadt nur
noch ein ziel schnell weg von hier in
sicherheit jedoch sind die straßen
verstopft und die mitfahrgelegenheiten
sind rar
taxiunternehmen und fahrdienste kaum zu
erreichen und komplett ausgebucht die
preise haben sich über nacht
vervielfacht groß ist der andrang an den
bushaltestellen
ich will zu meinen eltern die wohnen auf
dem lande da ist es sicherer
auf dem luftweg gibt es jedenfalls kein
entkommen der flughafen ist lahmgelegt
auch hier wurde am morgen geschützfeuer
vernommen und den luftraum über der
ukraine meiden die meisten fluglinien
schon seit tagen
unser flug wurde wegen des
kriegsausbruchs abgesagt und nun erklärt
uns keiner was passiert und was wir tun
sollen keiner gibt uns eine antwort wie
es nun weitergehen soll
die hauptstädter sollen sich in den
bunkeranlagen aus der zeit des kalten
krieges in sicherheit bringen die
stahltüren und der dicke beton sollen
artilleriebeschuss und luftangriffen
standhalten
alle bürger sind informiert über die
zugänge zu unseren schutzräumen und
können dort zuflucht suchen wer nicht in
der kritischen infrastruktur arbeitet er
soll zu hause bleiben und sich
bereithalten verfolgen sie die
nachrichten und bleiben sie ruhig
dass die angst vor einem angriff der
drei millionen metropole nicht
unbegründet ist bewies einen
raketenanschlag der die anwohner einer
geschäftsstraße im süden der stadt am
vormittag aufschreckte gezielter
beschuss oder ein irrläufer
es gab keinen rauch und auch keinen
geruch ich wusste nicht was passiert ist
ich bin fassungslos da waren doch auch
passanten mit einkaufstaschen und kinder
unterwegs
bevor er den befehl zum angriff auf die
ukraine gab legte kremlchef putin
gestern noch einen kranz am grab des
unbekannten soldaten nieder es war der
sogenannte tag der vaterland beschützer
und als dieser tag zu ende ging setzte
der präsident seine armeen in bewegung
unsere landsleute in der ost ukraine
sind seit acht jahren der folter und dem
völkermord des regimes in kiew
ausgesetzt unser ziel ist nicht die
besetzung der ukraine sondern nur ihre
entnazifizierung und entmilitarisierung
behauptet er
und an die adresse des westens dem er am
vergangenen wochenende mit einem großen
raketen manöver zeigte wie ernst es ihm
ist hatte er gestern auch noch eine
warnung
sollte sich jemand einmischen wollen und
uns gar bedrohungen dann wird unsere
antwort unmittelbar erfolgen und zu
konsequenzen führen die einmalig sind in
der geschichte
als dann am nachmittag die ersten
feindlichen hubschrauber über kiew
kreisten waren bereits über 200 angriffe
der russen gemeldet worden aus dem
ganzen land
selbst ganz im westen dem alten lemberg
nahe der polnischen grenze treiben angst
und unsicherheit die menschen zu den
geldautomaten
manche wollen ihr erspartes retten
andere brauchen es für die flucht
genau dort in lemberg im westen der
ukraine
dort haben sirenen heute früh vor
russischen luftangriffen gewarnt in der
stadt die die ukraine ruf nennen und die
nicht weit von der polnischen grenze
entfernt ist wir sehen ist auf der karte
ganz links etwa 50 kilometer von der
polnischen grenze beobachtet mein
kollege sebastian eben den ganzen tag
über schon die lage sebastian in welcher
verfassung befinden sich die einwohner
von lemberg haben die noch die hoffnung
von der russischen großoffensive
verschont zu bleiben
also hier macht sich eigentlich niemand
mehr die illusion dass das hier noch gut
ausgeht die menschen hier in davis oder
länder bis auf deutsch heißt haben
natürlich große angst dass das was wir
aus kiew hören sirenengeheul menschen in
luftschutzbunkern dass ihnen das hier
auch blüht und ich habe vorher war ich
an bankautomaten und habe mit den leuten
gesprochen die holen sich jetzt das geld
wie wir gerade auch schon in dem beitrag
gesehen haben es gibt bei supermärkten
werden die gehen die leute zum brot
kaufen kauft decken sich ein ich habe
mit vielen menschen gesprochen die
gesagt haben sie fliegen jetzt erstmal
noch nicht bleiben noch da aber wir
haben auch einige menschen gesehen die
hier mit koffern unterwegs sind zum
nächsten bus bahnhof oder zum zug zum
bahnhof mit zug um zug zu finden das
heißt die lemberger decken sich ein mit
dem was sie brauchen sie holen bargeld
ab aber offenbar nehmen sie im moment
noch abstand von einer fluchtbewegung
die am nachbarland polen erwartet wird
es gibt leute die hier sich auf die
flucht machen das haben wir gesehen wir
haben auch gehört dass es hunderte
menschen geben soll die in polen über
die grenze wollen es wird auch erwartet
dass das noch viel mehr werden je
nachdem wie die russischen truppen
vorstoßen wir hören im moment dass
russische truppen sich richtung
tschernobyl auf machen auch vor gift das
haben wir gerade auch in den beitrag
gesehen auch von süden sollen sie kommen
also hier in lembeck macht sich keiner
die illusion dass das hier noch ein
besonders sicherer ort ist sebastian
wenn wir jetzt mal den blick weiten über
die stadtgrenzen von lemberg hinaus und
zu mal auf die militärische lage in der
gesamten ukraine schauen zur stunde die
behörden sollen ja die kontrolle über
weite teile des südens verloren haben es
gibt ein meldungen von nach russischer
truppen auf dem militärflugplatz see
nahe kiew eingenommen haben gibt es
bestätigungen bei ihnen im westen der
ukraine wie ist die gesamte militärische
lage im moment zu bewerten
das lässt sich von hier aus sehr
schwierig ist sehr schwer beurteilen wir
können nur auf das hören was wir von dem
ukrainischen militär lesen oder von
russischen nachrichten seiten sehen
richtig unabhängig beurteilen was
wirklich militärisch im land los ist das
können wir von hier aus leider nicht was
erwarten die menschen jetzt in lemberg
gerade auch von europa von der
westlichen welt die sich jetzt in
unterschiedlichen formaten jahr beraten
wird heute abend die 27 staats und
regierungschefs der europäischen union
dann morgen einen krisengipfel der nato
was sind das für erwartungen was muss
der westen jetzt tun
also es gibt zwei sachen in dieser
ganzen thematik zum einen die normalen
menschen die erwarten hilfsgüter aber
auch ganz konkret waffen zur
verteidigung die sollen die länder aus
dem westen liefern und dann gibt es die
politische seite ich habe gerade einen
tweet vom außenminister der ukraine von
metro kollege lesen der ganz klar sagt
ich will höre jetzt auf diplomatisch zu
sein ich fordere vom westen dass
russland aus dem swift transaktions
system also dem finanz transaktions
systems wirft herausgenommen wird und
das ist eine konkrete forderung das soll
möglichst bald passieren und dann
fordert er auch dass der westen die
diplomatischen beziehungen zu russland
abbricht das sind konkrete forderungen
die die ukrainische politik stellt das
sind forderungen aus kiel für den
vermutlich aber die europäer nur zum
teil nachkommen werden wie es im moment
aussieht wird die eu heute abend nicht
entscheiden aus dem internationalen
finanzsystems hilft auszusteigen darüber
werden wir auch im laufe der sendung
noch sprechen und nach brüssel schalten
sebastian eben eins von vielen danke für
diese auskünfte nach lemberg und passen
sie auf sich auf
heute früh um 6 uhr moskauer zeit hat
sich vladimir putin zu wort gemeldet mit
einer rede an die nation und das war
faktisch eine kriegserklärung an die
ukraine und auch eine offen feindselige
botschaft an den westen fragen wir nach
bei vilbeler in moskau die diese rede
heute früh gehört hat für
womit hat denn putin eigentlich den
einmarsch diese grossoffensive diese
invasion im nachbarland begründet
also seine erste begründung war die die
wir den letzten wochen und sogar monaten
wirklich oft gehört haben nämlich dass
die nato osterweiterung
russland bedrohen dass die nato russland
zu nahe gerückt sei das wie gesagt war
soweit nichts neues aber dann ging er
weiter und hat gesagt dass im don was
ein völkermord stattfindet dass die
ukraine dort also ein genozid gegen die
im donbass lebenden menschen
veranstalter und dem müsse russland
einheit gebieten dazu muss man ganz klar
sagen dass das eine falschaussage ist es
gibt keinen völkermord der derzeitigen
gorgon was stattfindet das dritte große
argument dass wladimir putin in dieser
rede an gebracht hat war dass man die
ukraine entnazifiziert müsste auch da
ist nicht ganz klar auf was er sozusagen
diese begründung
auf was diese begründung beruhen soll
das dass die jeder dass die regierung in
kiew demokratisch gewähltes ist ja
offensichtlich
putin spricht er nicht von krieg gegen
die ukraine die ihr oft ja als bruder
volk sogar bezeichnete auch in den
letzten tagen spricht von einer sonder
militär operation ja quasi zur befreiung
der ukraine von einem angeblichen nazi
regime nehmen die russen ihm das
wirklich ab und wie groß ist die
zustimmung zu dieser invasion im
nachbarland
also wir haben dazu heute nachmittag mal
unsere eigene umfrage hier auf moskaus
straßen gestartet die ist natürlich in
keiner weise repräsentativ aber es war
eben doch ein ganz interessantes bild
das sich gezeigt hat denn die ältere
generation die älteren russinnen und
russen die wir befragt haben die haben
er quasi die waren auf putins linie die
haben teilweise wortwörtlich das
wiederholt was er in seiner rede heute
morgen gesagt hat und was natürlich den
ganzen tag über hier im staatlich
kontrollierten fernsehen rauf und runter
gespielt wurden also die sehen dass
diese militäroffensive tatsächlich
sinnvoll sei ein ganz anderes bild gab
es bei den jüngeren russinnen und russen
viel mehr krieg skepsis zu spüren unter
den menschen die sich sicherlich aus
anderen quellen auch informieren und es
gab heute auch im ganzen land verteilt
den versuch einzelne proteste zumindest
gegen den krieg zu starten die polizei
hat diese versuche allerdings immer
sofort beendet dass es nicht gewollt
dass offen gegen putins weg demonstriert
wird die russischen streitkräfte führen
wir nochmal über die kriegsziele ganz
kurze sprechen sind ja in den
morgenstunden an gleich mehreren flanken
vorgerückt zu rücken nun möglicherweise
auch auf kiew zu es gibt auch berichte
wonach sie das ehemalige atomkraftwerk
tschernobyl einnehmen wollen hat sich
putin heute morgen öffentlich zu den
kriegs zielen erklärt
nein also in seiner rede hat er nicht
genau definiert was sozusagen der ziel
dieses krieges sein soll er hat nicht
gesagt wann dieses ziel erreicht sei
wann der krieg dann wieder beendet sei
es ist ja so dass im moment
offensichtlich vor allem
ukrainische militärische infrastruktur
ins visier genommen wird durchaus eben
auch in der nähe von den großen städten
auch in der nähe der hauptstadt kiew das
könnte darauf hindeuten dass das
vorbereitungen sind wie es dann im
zweiten schritt der russischen dem
russischen militär einfacher machen
würden mehr land im donbass zu gewinnen
territorium das über die derzeitigen
selbsternannten volksrepublik von lohans
grund und jetzt hinausgeht aber das ist
wirklich nur eines von undenkbar vielen
szenarien und ich denke man sollte da im
moment auch noch nicht weiter
spekulieren ob das am ende tatsächlich
sogar die bedingungslose kapitulation
die entwaffnung sozusagen der ukraine
sein wird das allein war es wohl im
moment nur der mann im kreml für gedanke
für diese ausführlichen auskünfte nach
moskau
ja nun also hat einen krieg begonnen in
denen zwar die nato ja nicht unmittelbar
verwickelt ist der das bündnis aber
fordert wie vielleicht noch nie seit
seiner gründung im april 1949 schon in
den vergangenen wochen hatte die allianz
ihre ostflanke vor allem polen rumänien
die baltischen staaten mit zusätzlichen
soldaten verstärkt denn groß ist die
angst der östlichen mitglieder dass
putins imperialen streben auch sie
bedrohen könnte entsprechend haben
einige von ihnen heute artikel 4 des
nordatlantik vertrags aktiviert und eine
dringlichkeitssitzung der nato beantragt
über die ergebnisse richtet florian a
und dass sie als trio auftreten passiert
eher selten am tag des russischen
angriffs aber scheint es nötig
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen und eu-ratspräsident michelle
haben eine gemeinsame botschaft an
russland und die welt
das ist barbarisch wir verurteilen das
aufs äußerste wir befinden uns in einem
ernsten moment für europas sicherheit
geht hier nicht nur um den song passt
nicht nur um die ukraine es geht hier um
die stabilität von europa der welt und
unsere friedensordnung
die nato aktiviert ihren verteidigungs
plan für osteuropa heißt sie verlegt
weitere truppen in die östlichen
mitgliedstaaten zur verteidigung ein
eingreifen in der ukraine nicht mitglied
der nato schließt die allianz aber aus
derweil kündigt die eu weitere
sanktionen gegen russland an am abend
dazu ein sondergipfel der staats- und
regierungschefs in brüssel
die eu
und ihre mitgliedstaaten werden
gemeinsam mit ihren verbündeten russland
zur rechenschaft ziehen auf dem gipfel
werden wir uns im grundsatz auf ein
neues paket von massiven und gezielten
sanktionen einigen tip-off meister die
sessions im gespräch etwa das einfrieren
von russischen vermögen in der eu oder
ein exportverbot von
schlüsseltechnologien etwa in der luft
und raumfahrt
songs und auch die sanktionen werden der
aggressionen russlands gegenüber
angemessen sein und wir werden
militärisch wirtschaftlich oder im
bereich der energie keine schwäche
zeigen muss oft keine schwäche zeigen
dass so die kommissionspräsidentin gelte
auch wenn menschen vor dem krieg nach
europa fliehen
wir hoffen dass es so wenige flüchtlinge
wie möglich geben wird aber wir sind
vorbereitet und sie sind willkommen
europa hatte wochen lang zeit sich auf
eine solche eskalation einzustellen
offenbar so wirkt es heute hat man die
zeit genutzt
und wir nutzen jetzt die zeit für ein
gespräch mit bundeswehr-general hd hans
lothar domröse guten abend nach
oldenburg
genau darum brüssel für morgen hat die
nato also einen krisengipfel der staats
und regierungschefs anberaumt heute ja
bereits die dringlichkeitssitzung auf
botschafter ebene was kann was muss das
bündnis in dieser schwierigen lage jetzt
leisten
senator tritt zusammen vermute in
artikel 4 das heißt man berät sich wenn
eine unvorhergesehene lage kommt und die
haben wir jetzt mit dem überfall auch
die ukraine putin generiert sich als
kriegsverbrecher und darauf muss man
reagieren
die alarmstufen der einzelnen verbände
werden sicherlich heruntergeschraubte zu
zeiten und sie wissen ja dass
deutschland als beispiel nach litauen
drucken verlegt hat die amerikaner nach
polen um nur wenige zu nennen also wir
passen auf und müssen das nato
territorium und die bevölkerung schützen
wenn es zum schlimmsten kommen was ich
nicht annehmen wo sie artikel 4 des nato
vertrages erwähnen der amerikanische
außenminister blinken hat ja heute die
bedeutung des beistands artikels 5
betonte der oberbefehlshaber der
streitkräfte bekommt auch das ist ein
beschluss von heute weitreichende
befugnisse wie sehr fühlt sich das
bündnis aus ihrer sicht im moment selbst
bedroht durch russlands vorgehen wie
groß ist die angst dass russland auch
dann auch über grenzen in richtung nato
übergehen könnte
ich würde es nicht anders nennen sondern
wachsamkeit ist der preis der freiheit
wir haben ja lange überlegen für jahr
lang oder noch länger für ein halbes
leben was will präsident vorsehen jetzt
wissen wir es nach seiner schrecklichen
ukraine rede hat er ja gesagt festlegung
sommers oder johann soder wunders es
geht um die ukraine rwe entnazifiziert
und entwaffnen und da sehen wir jetzt
gerade und schriftlich mitgeteilt hatte
er der nato für verhandlungen schon im
dezember und davor dass er die linie von
1997 wieder haben will dh die nato in
die neue nato wenn sie so wollen alles
auswärts deutschlands wäre zur frage
gestellt wie er das fordert und die
können nicht zustimmen deswegen müssen
wir aufpassen dass die neuen länder
polen und das baltikum insbesondere
geschützt werden das ist ein auto
territorium keinen zentimeter drüber
weil in eschen eschen und das würde
weltweit bedeuten sprechen wir doch mal
über putin dessen armada nun seit
mindestens zwölf stunden einem
beispiellosen angriff auf die ukraine
gestartet hat zu lande zu wasser und in
der luft von mehreren franken aus was
können sie als ehemaliger general
strategisch aus diesem vorgehen heraus
lesen welche militärischen ziele
verfolgt russland offenbar
naja der präsident spricht vorab den
spricht von entwaffnung das heißt das
ganze land sie versuchen eine
enthauptungsschlag die führung muss raus
genommen werden also die
führungszentralen kiew die hauptstadt
muss umlagert werden besetzt werden die
flughäfen müssen zerstört werden aus
russischer sicht und die spezialkräfte
sind ohnehin schon drin um das heißt mit
allen nähten also zu land zur luft mit
drohnen zu wasser mit landung werten in
einem kreis folgende angriff setzt er an
die ukrainischen streitkräfte übrigens
wie jedes einzelne land ist eine
hightech armee unterlegen und sie werden
jetzt verzettelt sie wissen nicht ob sie
nach norden gehen sollen osten oder
westen weil es überall rauch und ich
denke er wird versuchen einen
hautausschlag die hauptstadt einnehmen
und danach eine marionette und die
ukraine in die knie zwingen danach eine
marine da einsetzen und die kabuler
kapitulation
das zu verhindern versuchen zumindest
die ukrainischen streitkräfte die sich
jetzt ja dieser 200.000 mann starken
russischen armada entgegenstellen
glauben sie dass diese armee den russen
überhaupt etwas entgegensetzen kann und
wenn ja was
der kinder nein wir haben immer gesagt
die allianz ist die allianz weil ein
land alleine gegen eine weltmacht es nie
schaffen wird
carina hat russisches sowjetisches altes
material sie ist von mir aus gut
ausgebildet aber sie ist nicht trainiert
in allen domain luft cyber marine land
alles gleichzeitig ich behaupte das
können nur wenige
und die russen können das also bleibt
nur die guerilla taktik übrig in dem
moment wo sie sich breit aufstellen
werden sie auch geschossen ich fürchte
so leid mir dass du mein herz blutet die
ukraine werden diese schlacht nicht
gewinnen können und das obwohl
verschiedene nato länder unter anderem
die usa aber auch die briten der ukraine
ja in den letzten wochen waffen
geliefert haben flugabwehrwaffen
panzerabwehrraketen war das am ende doch
nur der tropfen auf den heißen stein
mein englisch aber letztlich
zu einem gerätetraining gute ausbildung
und logistik sie können natürlich seine
hand happens über der schulter tragen
und ich sage ja aus dem keller heraus
habe stehe ich auch irgendwo bei
vorhandene panzer machen das können die
und das wünsche ich auch viel erfolg
aber sie können nicht einfach ein
waffensystem einführen das dauert ja
ewig bis sie die soldaten trainiert
haben wie realistisch es ist gut gemeint
heute können sie manchmal sie wollen die
russen sind in euro millions überlegen
hause überlegen leider hat humor so
sprechen wir vielleicht doch über die
menschen in der ukraine die jetzt
natürlich zu tausenden vielleicht zu
opfern dieser kriegerischen
auseinandersetzungen werden könnten
moskau versichert die zivilbevölkerung
auch gerade die in den großstädten
müssen sich keine sorgen machen man habe
ist nur auf militärische ziele abgesehen
können sie den glauben schenken wie
gefährdet ist die zivilbevölkerung in
der ukraine
sie ist grundsätzlich gefährdet aber ich
glaube dass das kein soldaten schlachter
ist das muss ich auch den russischen
soldaten und darstellen sie wollen die
herrscher farben sie wollen die
regierung nehmen sie wollen die
führungszentralen nehmen sie wollen
durch cyber alles still legen sie haben
kein interesse das volk zu bringen
wollen dass folgte ein bildern und zu
freunden machen das würde ich glauben
obwohl man dem präsidenten natürlich
nicht
hoffen wir dass der zivilbevölkerung in
der ukraine und zwar in allen
landesteilen auch im osten das
schlimmste erspart bleibt und wir nicht
über jahrhunderte tausende tote gab
verletzte werden berichten müssen aber
da ist zunächst einmal der wunsch vater
des gedanken ist hans lothar domröse ich
danke ihnen für diese auskünfte und ich
glaube es wird nicht das letzte mal in
diesen tagen gewesen sein dass wir ihre
expertise einfangen vielen dank nach
oldenburg vielen dank herr cleaner
ein schrecklicher tag sagt er noch ja
der europäische chor ist vielstimmig an
diesem tag eine mischung könnte man
sagen aus blanken entsetzen über den
russischen vormarsch laute vorwürfe und
vor allem strafandrohungen an die
adresse moskaus erste wirtschafts und
finanzsanktionen hatte die europäische
union ja bereits verhängt heute abend
nun beim krisen gipfel der 27
der wurde um 20 uhr beginnen soll werden
sicher weitere maßnahmen folgen fragen
wir nach bei anne gellinek in brüssel
eine ja welche sanktionen plante nach
jetzigem stand der dinge die eu das ist
sozusagen teil zwei des großen sanktions
pakets das die eu staats und
regierungschefs die außenminister und
die botschafter eigentlich seit wochen
verhandeln für den fall dass russland in
die ukraine einmarschiert jetzt ist der
fall eingetreten und deshalb kommt jetzt
ein paket mit härteren maßnahmen es
besteht aus drei teilen
das eine sind finanzsanktionen also
russische banken sollen auf die liste
gesetzt werden mit ihnen werden
geschäfte verboten sie dürfen nicht mehr
auf europäischen kapitalmärkten agieren
und auch kein geld mehr leihen das ist
der eine teil der zweite teil sind
exportverbote technologie die russland
dringend brauche so die eu zum beispiel
für die öl- und gasförderung darf nicht
mehr exportiert werden auch
flugzeugtechnik und raumfahrt teile
dürften nicht mehr exportiert werden man
setzt darauf dass das langfristig die
russische industrie und wirtschaft
schädigen wird und der dritte teil sind
einreisebeschränkungen über die listung
von personen hinaus die wir ja gestern
schon gesehen haben 500 menschen
ungefähr darüber will man jetzt noch mal
reden und für recht breitere kreise aus
putins regierung mit einreiseverboten
belegen offenbar alle besteht aber
uneinig seit dem kreis der 27 darüber ob
man russland doch sofort aus dem
internationalen zahlungssystemen schrift
ausschließen soll da gibt es offenbar
sorge um die eigenen gläubiger
russischer unternehmen auf dem
kontinente was steckt dahinter ja das
ist tatsächlich so diese dieses scharfe
schwert dieses schärfste schwert auf dem
gebiet der finanzsanktionen wird seit
wochen diskutiert es ist immer mal
wieder ins spiel gebracht worden es
würde ja bedeuten wenn man russland vom
internationalen finanzsystem abschnitte
dem sind ungefähr 11.000 banken
angeschlossen und es würde bedeuten dass
russland keine internationalen geschäfte
mehr tätigen kann das aber auch exporte
und importe von und nach russland nicht
mehr bezahlt werden könnten jedenfalls
nicht mehr so einfach und das wiederum
hieße dass deutschland zum beispiel sein
gas nicht bezahlen könnte dass es aus
russland bekommt deshalb gibt es sehr
viele vorbehalte gegen dieses system ist
wäre sehr wirksam es würde die russische
wirtschaft sehr stark angreifen aber es
würde eben auch die europäische
wirtschaft betreffen besonders
deutschland und die niederlande und die
sind eben auch die bremse im aktuellen
vorschlag der eu-kommission der heute
abend bei den staats und regierungschefs
diskutiert wird stets hilft nicht drauf
es scheint als würde sich europa wieder
einmal selbst eines scharfen schwertes
gegenüber russland beraten wir werden
sehen was am ende dabei herauskommt
danke nach brüssel
es ist ein krieg der alle europäer
besorgt in besonderer weise aber die
westlichen nachbarn der ukraine die
polen eine
526 kilometer lange grenze verbindet die
beiden länder werden demnächst wieder
russischer soldaten auf der anderen
seite stehen fragt man sich in polen
besorgt und was ist wenn diese grenze
für zehntausende vielleicht
hunderttausend der ukraine zum fluchtweg
nach europa wird schon vor tagen warnte
der polnische ministerpräsident vor
einem exodus aus dem nachbarland begeht
nichts wie raus nichts wie weg vitali
und alle kassandra haben mit ihrer
kleinen familie die ukraine am morgen
fluchtartig verlassen nun sind sie in
polen angst verzweiflung und
fassungslosigkeit
man hat mir gesagt ich sei panisch es
werde schon nichts passieren
aber nun ist es doch wahr geworden
ich kann es noch nicht fassen wir müssen
hier verlassen das ist alles was wir
noch haben
wir gehen jetzt nach polen vielleicht
später nach zypern dort haben wir
freunde da können wir bleiben bis das
schlimmste die angriffe vielleicht ein
bisschen weniger werden
viele von ihnen hier kommen aus lemberg
nur 70 kilometer von der polnischen
grenze entfernt die zukunft ungewiss in
der polnischen stadt wesel nur wenige
kilometer entfernt ruft der heutige tag
erinnerungen an 2014 wach damals hat das
ukrainische kulturzentrum geflüchtete
aus den umkämpften gebieten der ukraine
aufgenommen an die 50 menschen kann es
auch jetzt wieder unterkunft und
erstversorgung anbieten das ist der
theatersaal normalerweise finden hier
konzerte statt für flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine können wir hier die stühle
entfernen das technische equipment
abbauen und einige dutzend feldbetten
aufstellen damit die menschen sich hier
erholen können
am frühen morgen sind es noch wenige
menschen die hier am polnisch
ukrainischen grenze übergang ankommen
aber die angst sind der bevölkerung
wächst und so stellt sich polen auf eine
große zahl von geflüchteten menschen wie
vitali und alle kassandra und ihre
kleine familie
ja und wenn was wir hoffen die leitungen
steht werden wir auch unsere polen
korrespondent in die schläger noch
schalten die sich an die polnisch
ukrainischen grenze begeben hat der
krieg in der ukraine ist ja keine
angelegenheit aus der sich der rest
europas oder der welt einfach so heraus
halten könnte nur weil die kämpfe nicht
unmittelbar vor unserer haustür toben
das gilt umso mehr für menschen die
angehörige oder freunde in der ukraine
haben sie schauen heute mit brennender
sorge gen osten bei uns in deutschland
sind das vor allem die hier lebenden
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer gut 300.000
sollen das sein eine gruppe die schon
einmal nämlich nach der annexion der
krim 2014 gewachsen ist und nun weiteren
zulauf bekommen könnte dominik müller
roche hat sich umgehört
seit über 20 jahren leben dimitri
fuhrmann und seine frau irina in köln
doch gedanklich mit dem herzen sind
beide heute weit weg dimitri fuhrmann
stammt aus charkiw seine mutter dort hat
er bislang noch nicht erreichen können
aber zum glück seinen oder und seinen
cousin die ihm am telefon von
explosionen und einpflegen berichten
als männer die ruhe zu bewahren
es ist schock im schwimmen können sie
von köln aus helfen gerne würden sie
ihre angehörigen irgendwie zu sich nach
deutschland in sicherheit lotsen doch im
moment können sie nicht viel tun weit
über 100.000 ukraine leben in
deutschland und sind heute wie hier in
köln fassungslos und den sorge
meine kinder ist auch reihenhäuser
und zurück haben wir aus der ukraine und
diese putin was
ich habe nicht schlecht gesagt aber das
ist mein herz und meine
dimitri fuhrmann fordert von deutschland
vom westen maximale unterstützung für
die ukraine und harte sanktionen liegen
putin nur so lässt sich in seinen augen
das schlimmste noch abwenden
ich wünsche mir
etwas schärfe worte und taten gegen
diese angriffe diesen krieg das diesen
so frieden bruch also das macht uns
wirklich seelisch kaputt da möchten wir
dass etwas passiert und schon heute oder
gestern
dimitri fuhrmann verdient sein geld als
karikaturist was hat putin mit der welt
vor allem hofft er dass seine familie
und alle menschen in der ukraine da
irgendwie nochmal heil aus allem raus
kommen
und von deutschland aus schauen wir
jetzt noch einmal über den atlantik dann
natürlich richten sich die augen der
europäer auf den mächtigsten mann der
welt auf us präsident joe biden der aber
nicht zu mächtig war die russin von
einem angriffskrieg schlussendlich
abzuhalten fragen wir mrt wissen vor dem
weissen haus zumindest vor dem foto des
weißen hauses in washington immer was
hört man heute von joe biden die
reagiert die amerikanische führung auf
diese große invasion der russen
ja die amerikaner sagen ganz klar das
war ein provozierter krieg sie werfen
putin vor dass er für den tod und die
zerstörung in der ukraine jetzt
verantwortlich ist und dass die welt
ihnen dafür zur rechenschaft ziehen
werde das ist das was der präsident in
der nacht schon gesagt hat er wird
innerhalb der nächsten stunde wohl hier
auch vor die presse treten und
sanktionen verkünden aber das was sich
momentan hier ergibt ein bild aus der
ukraine ist etwas was die amerikaner
sehr besorgt das pentagon hat verfolgt
auf welche positionen die russischen
truppen gezogen sind welche ziele sie
angegriffen haben und es sieht alles
danach aus als wolle russland
tatsächlich kiew ein kessel
möglicherweise erobern und am ende ein
pro russisches regime dort installieren
so hört man aus dem amerikanischen
pentagon und dazu wird der präsident
sicherlich dann nachher ausstellung
nehmen damit würden sich die schlimmsten
befürchtungen auch der amerikaner
bewahrheiten sprechen wir vielleicht
über mögliche sanktionen von denen sie
gesagt haben dass joe biden heute
weitere verkünden wird erst vorgestern
hatten die amerikaner ja eine tranche an
sanktionen gegen russland verhängen
zuletzt sogar gegen die
betreibergesellschaft der deutsch
russischen pipeline nord stream 2 aber
wie die mutter aller sanktionen wirkt er
das ja noch nicht was wird da
wahrscheinlich heute noch kommen
ja ähnlich wie das was wir vor ihnen
auch schon von der europäischen union
gehört haben was da zu erwarten ist es
wird sich in erster linie gegen fünf der
größten banken in russland richten diese
bankenwerte neben ausgekoppelt aus dem
internationalen finanzsystem
die sind sehr wichtig für die russische
wirtschaft zum zweiten wird man eben
gegen hochtechnologie
exportkontrollen verhängen das bedeutet
dass beispielsweise irgendwelche waren
und güter in denen amerikanische
technologie enthalten ist software
halbleiter mikrochips all das nicht mehr
nach russland geliefert werden könnten
das würde die rüstungs und die
luftfahrtindustrie in russland sehr
stark treffen die amerikaner haben auch
noch ein sehr schwer scharfes schwert
das sind eben sanktionen gegen einzelne
personen es wird nicht ausgeschlossen
dass es auch sanktionen direkte gegen
wladimir putin geben würde das würde
bedeuten dass sein guthaben wenn es sich
irgendwo im ausland befindet eingefroren
würde niemand mehr mit ihm geschäfte
machen dürfte und das fünfte und das ist
vielleicht das wichtigste sind
sanktionen gegen den energiesektor in
russland russland ist auf die einnahmen
aus öl und gas angewiesen natürlich sind
die europäer auch angewiesen auf gas und
öl aus russland
aber man hat in den vergangenen wochen
bei der vorbereitung der sanktionen auch
gleich sich auf den worst case
vorbereitet das heißt man hat die
vorräte aufgestockt man hat lieferungen
die nach asien gehen sollten von gas
nach europa umgeleitet man hat mit katar
einem der größten gaslieferanten
gesprochen und vereinbart dass katar
mehr gas dann liefern würde nach europa
also man ist recht zuversichtlich dass
diese energie sanktionen angeht europa
nicht so hart getroffen würde wie putin
sich das vielleicht vorstellt es sind
sanktionen schwerter die washington da
vorbereitet aber was oder welche
hoffnungen verbindet die amerikanische
führung eigentlich damit hofft man doch
noch putin irgendwie zum einlenken zu
einem umdenken bewegen zu können oder
ist das eben jetzt wirklich eine
folgenschwere bestrafung dessen was der
russische präsident jetzt in der ukraine
tut
ich glaube es ist eher das prinzip
hoffnung folgenschwere bestrafung und
dann hofft man dass über einen gewissen
zeitraum über die nächsten wochen monate
möglicherweise die folgen dieser
sanktionen in russland so zu spüren sind
dass der druck auf vladimir putin wächst
das was jetzt passiert wird man mit
diesen sanktionen nicht verhindern
können putin ist dabei europa komplett
zu verändern die europäische ordnung der
nato geht es ja in erster linie jetzt
darum sicherzustellen dass nicht nato
territorium in irgendeiner weise auch
angegriffen wird kann es sehr sensible
situationen geben in den nächsten tagen
und wochen war ja zb die
kommunikationsinfrastruktur der ukraine
oder auch die energieinfrastruktur eng
mit westeuropäischen staaten verbunden
ist da könnte es dann zu situationen
kommen die man als angriff auf die nato
an sieht also es kommt in erster linie
darauf an dass man putin davon
abschreckt weiter vorzudringen und in
zweiter linie in der hoffnung dass die
sanktionen wirkung entfalten vielleicht
eine politische lösung in absehbarer
zeit herbeizuführen und in der tat die
vereinigten staaten haben große
militärische verantwortung auch in
europa sind der mit abstand die stärkste
kraft innerhalb der nato morgen wird
auch präsident beiden ja eben an diesem
sondergipfel dem digitalen der allianz
teilnehmen was leitet den washington
jetzt in strategisch militärischer
hinsicht worum geht es jetzt den
amerikanern in den nächsten tagen
ja die sicherung der nato in aller
erster linie und man wird sich
vielleicht an den gedanken gewöhnen
müssen dass russland in verschiedenen
bereichen wieder ganz nah an die nato
heranrückt an die polnische grenze
möglicherweise deswegen wird massiv
werden die truppen verstärkt an der
ostflanke der nato es ist immer ein
risiko dabei dass putin möglicherweise
das potenzial was er in der vergangenen
nacht angedroht hat auch einsetzen
könnte das klingt wahnsinnig das klingt
sehr abwegig aber mittlerweile traut man
ihm zu dass er über den einsatz von
atomwaffen zumindest nachdenkt oder sie
als mittel zur abschreckung wirklich
einsetzen will also die nato wird vieles
zu bereden haben und eine strategie
entwickeln müssen gegen 1 ich sag mal
ausgedehntes russland mit einem
machthaber der unberechenbar und welche
strategie das unter amerikanischer
führung sein könnte das wird dieser
gipfel morgen der 30 nato-länder
sicherlich ausbaldowern und wir sind
gespannt was am ende dabei herauskommt
und in der tat es scheint als sei
jedenfalls putin von seinem kriegsrat
ihn eingeschlagen hat so nicht mehr
abzubringen m at wissen danke für diese
ausführlichen auskünfte nach washington
für die westliche welt ist die
gemengelage ja eindeutig russland führt
krieg gegen einen souveränen staat durch
putins brille liest sich das allerdings
ganz anders er spricht von
selbstverteidigung von entnazifizierung
der ukraine für ihn ist die ukraine
ohnehin kein richtiger staat vielmehr
ein produkt der sowjetunion die
regierung in kiew ein marionettenregime
des westens der geschichte so verbiegt
glaubt auch die gegenwart nach gutdünken
verändern zu dürfen aber auf welche
geschichte schaut die ukraine in
wahrheit zurück und was verbindet sie
historisch mit russland dominika meister
klärt auf
im mittelalter war kiew die hauptstadt
des alten osmanischen reiches wie
russland und belarus versteht sich die
ukraine als nachfolgestaat der
historischen kiefer russ die von der
ostsee bis zum schwarzen meer reichte
russland und die ukraine trägt eine
gemeinsame geschichte aber sind russen
und ukrainer deswegen 1 wie es putin
behauptet nein sagt der historiker aus
meiner sicht ist das eine geschichts
mystifikation
sehen sie deutschland und frankreich
haben ja zum beispiel auch einen
gemeinsamen ursprung im frankenreich
mittelalter aber niemand in frankreich
kämen doch auf die idee deutschland die
nationalstaatlichkeit
abzusprechen
jahrhunderte lang standen die ukraine
unter fremdherrschaft von russland polen
oder österreich ungarn im zarenreich war
die ukrainische sprache verboten
im ersten weltkrieg ließ der deutsche
kaiser truppen in der ukraine
einmarschieren mit dem kriegsende
entsteht nur kurz ein ukrainischer
nationalstaat der dann unter linien teil
der sowjetunion wird stalin ist 1932
verantwortlich für eine entsetzliche
hungersnot in der ukraine mindestens 3,5
millionen menschen sterben holodomor
eine politik der vernichtung es äußerte
sich nicht nur in dieser gezielt
herbeigeführten hungersnot der dreißiger
jahre sondern auch in kampagnen gegen
kritische intellektuelle
also es gegen stalin eindeutig darum
ukrainische identität zurückzudrängen
und von der sowjetischen völlig zu
überlagern
putin verschweigt dieses verbrechen an
dem ukrainischen volk in seiner rede er
sieht nur den zerfall der alten
sowjetunion
1991 erklärt die ukraine wie andere teil
staaten ihre unabhängigkeit
drei jahre später verzichtet kiew im
budapester memorandum auf atomwaffen im
gegenzug verpflichten sich die usa
russland und großbritannien
die souveränität der ukraine zu achten
dass diese
zusicherung jetzt nicht mehr zählen also
dass sie kein wirksamer schutz sind ist
bitter weil die ukraine ja damals waffen
abgegeben hat die sie heute durchaus
schützen würde 2004 die orangene
revolution der beginn der
westorientierung
2013 proteste auf dem majdan das
ukrainische volk strebt nach europa in
der folge spalten sich die separatisten
in der ost ukraine ab 2014 annektiert
putin die creme völkerrechtswidrig für
experten teil eines großen plans hat das
2014/15 umgesetzt was er vorhatte dann
setzt auch jetzt wieder um wasser fort
er sammelt offenbar die alten länder der
seines russlands und zwar nicht dass
sowjetischen russland sondern erscheint
mir das kaiserliche nur ist und das
möglichst große alte russland wieder
erstehen zu lassen also putin ist jemand
der an das glaubt was er sagt als
historische rechtfertigung annimmt und
er hat oberwasser heute morgen die
kriegserklärung putins an die ukraine
mit einem angriffskrieg will er die
geschichte zurückdrehen
ja an der entschlossenheit deutschlands
der westlichen welt will oder scholz der
kanzler keinerlei zweifel lassen welchen
weg deutschland in dieser beispiellosen
krise gehen will das erläutert oder
scholz nun in einer ansprache die wir
ihnen jetzt zeigen
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
heute ist ein furchtbarer tag für die
ukraine und ein düsterer tag für europa
wir alle sorgen und zum den frieden
ich kann mir gut vorstellen welche
fragen sie sich heute abend stellen mir
geht es da nicht anders die lage ist
sehr ernst
gerade erleben wir den beginn eines
krieges wie wir in europa so seit mehr
als 75 jahren nicht erlebt haben
russlands präsident putin hat die
entscheidung getroffen die ukraine
militärisch anzugreifen
das ist ein überfall auf ein
unabhängiges souveränes land er ist
durch nichts und durch niemanden zu
rechtfertigen es ist der versuch grenzen
innerhalb europas gewaltsam zu
verschieben ja vielleicht ein ganzes
land von der weltkarte zu tilgen
voller absicht präsident putin mit den
grundprinzipien der charta der vereinten
nationen und mit der europäischen
friedensordnung
er gefährdet das leben unzähliger
bürgerinnen und bürger der ukraine dem
bruder volk russlands all das geschieht
nicht weit weg von uns sondern hier in
europa gerade zwei flugstunden von
berlin entfernt sitzen moment familien
in luftschutzkellern
frauen männer und kinder bangen um ihr
leben
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer bewaffnen
sich um ihre heimat gegen eine invasion
summit zu verteidigen
in diesen schweren stunden sind unsere
gedanken bei den tapferen bürgern und
bürgern der ukraine
ich habe präsident zielinski heute
morgen in einem telefonat gesagt das
ukrainische volk und seine frei gewählte
regierung haben unsere volle solidarität
diese verletzung der souveränität der
ukraine durch russland werden wir nicht
hinnehmen
mit dem angriff auf die ukraine
präsident putin die zeit zurückdrehen
aber es gibt kein zurück in die zeit des
19 jahrhunderts als großmächte über die
köpfe kleinere staaten hinweg
entschieden
es gibt kein zurück in die zeit des
kalten krieges als supermächte die welt
unter sich aufteilten einflusszonen und
es gibt auch kein zurück in die zeit vor
1989 damals erkämpften die bürgern und
bürger in mittel und osteuropa sich ihre
freiheit und demokratie auch in unserem
land und in der ukraine
deshalb haben wir präsident putin wieder
und wieder vor einem krieg gegen die
ukraine gewarnt
noch vor einer woche habe ich persönlich
mehrere stunden mit ihm im kreml
diskutiert und ihm klar gesagt dieser
krieg wäre ein schwerer fehler er würde
damit auch dem russischen volk und der
zukunft seines eigenen landes schweren
schaden zufügen
präsident putin hat all die warnungen
und bemühungen um einen diplomatischen
ausweg in den wind geschlagen er allein
nicht das russische volk hat sich für
diesen krieg entschieden er allein trägt
dafür die volle verantwortung
dieser krieg ist putins krieg
abermals appelliere ich mit allem
nachdruck an präsident putin stellen sie
die kampfhandlungen unverzüglich ein
ziehen sie die russischen truppen aus
der ukraine zurück wieder rufen sie die
völkerrechtswidrige anerkennung der
gebiete dann jetzt und lohans bis
zuletzt haben während der
internationalen gemeinschaft auf dialog
gesetzt und das gespräch mit moskau
gesucht wir hatten hoffnung aber wir
waren nicht naiv
deshalb haben wir uns parallel auf
diesen ernstfall vorbereitet mit unseren
verbündeten und partnern in der
europäischen union in der nato und in
der g 7 haben wir uns auf ein ganzes
paket von wirtschaftssanktionen
verständigt unser ziel der russischen
führung klar zu machen für diese
aggression wird sie einen hohen preis
zahlen
bereits nach der anerkennung der gebiete
don jetzt und lohans durch russland
haben der erste sanktionen erlassen und
wir haben die zertifizierung der
gaspipeline nord stream zwei ausgesetzt
angesichts des heutigen überfalls auf
die ukraine verhängen wir weitere
tiefgreifende sanktionen sie werden die
russische wirtschaft hart treffen
gleichzeitig müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass dieser konflikt nicht auf weitere
länder europas übergreift ich bin mir
mit dem amerikanischen präsidenten und
unseren europäischen freunden einig dies
mit allen uns zur verfügung stehenden
mitteln zu verhindern
putin sollte die entschlossenheit der
nato nicht unterschätzen alle ihre
mitglieder zu verteidigen das gilt
ausdrücklich für unsere nato partner im
baltikum in polen und in rumänien in
bulgarien und in der slowakei ohne wenn
und aber
deutschland und seine verbündeten wissen
sich zu schützen
die wir mit bürgern und mitbürger wir
sind entschlossen und handeln
geschlossen darin liegt unsere stärke
als freie demokratie
putin wird nicht gewinnen die
bürgerinnen und bürger in der ukraine
wollen demokratie und freiheit und
europas zukunft wird eine zukunft in
frieden und freiheit seien
dafür werden wir sorgen gemeinsam mit
unseren freunden und partnern
soweit der eindringliche appell des
bundeskanzlers die ansprache von olaf
scholz ja in einer beispiellosen
krisensituation für unser land und das
nur wenige wochen nach dem amtsantritt
des neuen bundeskanzlers zugehört hat
auch theo koll unser hauptstadt
studioleiter in berlin theo wenn wir uns
nochmal die wichtigsten punkte aus
scholz ansprache herausnehmen was war
für sie die zentrale botschaft des
kanzlers also erstens das ist ein
überfall ist der durch nichts und
niemanden zu rechtfertigen dass putin
wolle die zeit zurückdrehen sagt der
kanzler aber es gebe kein zurück nicht
ins neunzehnte jahrhundert nicht in den
kalten krieg nicht in die zeit vor 1989
der ganze hat klargemacht es weder die
nato noch die bundeswehr militärisch
eingreifen das fand ich wichtig das
würde ihnen die katastrophe führen hat
er gesagt aber alle nato mitglieder
würden ohne wenn und aber geschützt und
das ist dann auch eine art militärischer
ansage putin allein trägt die
verantwortung für diesen krieg sagt olaf
scholz das ist putins krieger ruft den
auf seine truppen zurückzuziehen man
ahnt dass diese appelle zum minister in
moskau keine wirkung entfalten werden
scholz war ja in diesem konflikt lange
auch durchaus sehr zögerlich versucht er
nun auch mit dieser ansprache
gewissermaßen in die vorhand zu kommen
ja ich glaube dass versuchen alle aber
mein eindruck ist dass es eher dem
naturell des kanzlers entspricht sich
nur auf besonders festem boden von
kenntnissen zu bewegen und das hat
einfach lange gedauert bis er sich
sicher genug gefühlt hat im umgang mit
russland und mit putin was sich aber
dann auch bei erfahreneren
außenpolitikern wie beispielsweise mark
und anderen ja als trügerisch
herausgestellt hat ansgar angesichts der
brutalen und die jegliches recht
brechenden aggression ist im westen
niemand mehr in der vorhand die ex
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer hat es heute stellvertretend
sei deutlich gemacht wir hätten hat sie
geschrieben historisch versagt die lehre
der beiden kanzler schmidt und kohl sei
gewesen verhandeln ja aber aus aller
militärischen stärke die es der
gegenseite unmöglich macht nicht zu
verhandeln insofern ist die bisherige
politik in den brunnen gefallen
sanktionen hin oder her und dennoch hat
der kanzler auch über neue sanktionen
gesprochen der neue von der
bundesregierung aber sicher heute abend
auch auf europäischer ebene beschlossen
werden es gibt keine zeit zurück in die
zeit vor 1989 putin können sozusagen das
rad der zeit nicht zurückdrehen sagt
olaf scholz welche hoffnungen wird der
kanzlei mit den nun auch noch einmal
verschärften sanktionen auch denen die
in den nächsten tagen erwartet werden
welche hoffnungen verbindet er wohl
damit um ehrlich zu sein ich habe nicht
den eindruck dass jemand hier in berlin
noch große hoffnungen hat dass man putin
beeinflussen kann mit den sanktionen
das wird ihm wehtun aber das ist
natürlich im prinzip durchblutet alles
eingepreist
ist ich habe gestern jemanden gesprochen
er meinte aus der durchaus in führender
position
er sagte wenn putin wirklich in die
ukraine ein feld mit großer macht dann
dauert es 24 oder 48 stunden und dann
haben wir am ende eine art pro russische
provinz ukraine und das könnte durchaus
passieren
theo welches bild wenn wir ein bisschen
über die innenpolitik sprechen gibt denn
die koalition am heutigen tag ab es gab
ja im vorfeld durchaus auch differenzen
was etwa die zukunft der pipeline nord
stream 2 angeht gegen die die grünen
immer gewesen sind dann der bau auch die
spd sehr lange festgehalten hat davon
sind die sozialdemokraten in dieser
woche endgültig abgerückt
bietet die ampel koalition tatsächlich
ein geschlossenes bild ist sie in allen
punkten einig war sozusagen die
außenpolitik deutschlands in den
nächsten tagen und wochen angeht und die
erfordernisse die aus deutscher sicht ja
zu erfüllen sind
beides sie bietet ein einheitliches bild
nach außen in den beschlüssen aber
darunter sieht man deutliche
unterschiede so das ist bezieht sich
nicht nur auf
nord stream 2 wo man sich dann am ende
geeinigt hat sondern auch beispielsweise
auf waffenlieferungen ich glaube das was
wir erlebt haben beim besuch von robert
habeck in der ukraine vor vielen monaten
dass er sich für defensiv waffen
eingesetzt hat ist durchaus eine
position die es auch innerhalb der ampel
noch gibt die aber nicht zum tragen
kommt wir sehen aber auch im umfeld dass
immer mehr politiker auch bei der spd
sagen wir müssen über diese position
nachdenken im fall der ukraine dürfte
das zu spät sein jetzt waffen zu liefern
in einen solchen konflikt aber dass die
bundesregierung die bundesrepublik keine
waffen liefert das könnte möglicherweise
eine veränderung erfahren und doch auch
mehrere politiker vertreter der
ampelkoalition heute in verschiedenen
interviews immer wieder betont dass die
haltung keine waffen an die ukraine zu
liefern richtig gewesen ist dies ist
jedenfalls nicht jetzt ex post
gewissermaßen als fehler bezeichnet
worden dennoch interessant zu hören dass
das möglicherweise mit blick auf andere
konfliktgebiete der welt zu einer neuen
einschätzung auch dieser koalition
führen könnte ja wir haben es also
sowohl der spd-chef klingbeil hat heute
gesagt man müsse darüber nachdenken
es hat er an zwei stellen gesagt und
ganz besonders deutlich hat man es
gesehen bei einem der führenden
außenpolitiker der cdu bei norbert
röttgen der immer gesagt hat wir dürfen
keine waffen in die ukraine liefern und
der seine position jetzt auch überdacht
hat theo koll ich glaube das ist der
wenn auch bittere honig den wir zur
minute aus dieser ansprache des
bundeskanzlers saugen können eine
ansprache die sicher noch in die
nächsten tage hinein wirken wird auch
mit einer wird natürlich in der
bevölkerung die jetzt höchst
verunsichert ist über die geschehnisse
in der ukraine mit vielen ängsten sorgen
verbunden wie wir ja noch nicht genau
fassen können von denen wir nicht wissen
was davon tatsächlich noch realität wird
theo dank erstmal einstand für diese
auskünfte nach berlin
es ist gewiss liebe zuschauern und
zuschauer dass dieser tag als
rabenschwarzer in die europäische
geschichte eingehen wird fast 77 jahre
nach dem ende des zweiten weltkriegs
wird also ein unabhängiger staat von
seinem nachbarn angegriffen ja
überfallen und das mit einer begründung
die an noch dunklere zeiten erinnert
präsident putin rechtfertigt die von ihm
losgetretene der invasion in der ukraine
damit russlands sicherheit schützen zu
wollen einen genozid verhindern zu
wollen er wolle die ukraine
entmilitarisierung und entnazifizierung
die möglichen ziele putins haben wir in
dieser sendung schon einmal skizziert
bis hin zu einer kapitulation bis zu
einem marionettenregime in kiew ob das
tatsächlich passiert zur stunde weiß es
keiner aber die wahrheit ist doch hier
überfällt eine ruchlose goliath einen
weit unterlegenen david
am frühen morgen passiert was lange
befürchtet wurde der russische präsident
putin gibt den angriffsbefehl und droht
allen die sich von außen einmischen
könnten mit nie dagewesenen konsequenzen
russland sei für alles gerüstet die
führer der separatisten in den regionen
lugansk unterton jetzt karten russland
um militärische hilfe gegen angriffe
ukrainischer truppen gebeten heißt es
weiter diese hilfe würde russland nun
gewähren die folge bomben fallen auf die
ukraine explosionen sind in zahlreichen
städten zu hören auch russische
bodentruppen dringen laut
augenzeugenberichten in das ukrainische
staatsgebiet vor aus russland belarus
und von der annektierten halbinsel krim
auch über das schwarze meer rückt
russland vor soll am schwarzmeerhafen
odessa angelandet seien vor allem
militärstützpunkte sind zurzeit wohl
ziele der angriffe die ukrainische
regierung auf der anderen seite ruft
alle einsatzfähigen landsleute zu den
waffen um sich gegen den russischen
angriff auf ihr heimatland zu
verteidigen
wir haben schon damit begonnen waffen
auszugeben um unser land zu beschützen
werden wir sie weiter an jeden ausgeben
der bereit ist jeder der unsere
souveränität schützen will jeder der
kampf erfahrung hat und sich der
verteidigung anschließen kann sollte
sich green beim militär
die zivilbevölkerung versucht sich
derweil in sicherheit zu bringen die
straßen die aus der hauptstadt kiew
herausführen verstopft an vielen orten
schlangen vor tankstellen und
geldautomaten
kriegsrecht hier wird die panik
ausbrechen wo soll man die kinder
verstecken es gibt keine schutzräume es
gibt nichts es ist alles offen hier wo
soll ich hin
ich habe panik angst bin aufgeregt ich
weiß nicht wen ich um hilfe fragen
sollte es ist gruselig ich hätte nie
gedacht dass wir in eine solche
situation kommen heute morgen haben wir
die explosion gehört dann begann die
panik
zahlreiche tote und verletzte soll es
schon jetzt auf beiden seiten geben nach
angaben der ukrainischen regierung soll
das russische militär inzwischen sogar
bis nach kiel vorgedrungen sein
ja und da diese minuten häufen sich
natürlich auch die meldungen die ein
meldungen die uns über die nachrichten
ticker erreichen auch über den fortgang
der militärischen der kriegs
geschehnisse in der ukraine das
russische verteidigungsministerium gibt
jetzt an in der ukraine 83 landgestützte
tages also ziele zerstört zu haben all
das lässt sich natürlich zur minute und
auch zur stunde nicht überprüfen während
amerika und europa so bitter es klingt
eben doch nur die rolle des beobachters
bleibt wären menschen in der ukraine
wohl sterben und diejenigen die über
leben einer ziemlich unsicheren zukunft
entgegen gehen sebastian eben ist in
lemberg in der ukrainischen stadt wulff
also im äußersten westen der ukraine
gelegenen sebastian was bekommen sie
dort in der stadt über die wir sehen
inzwischen die dunkelheit
hereingebrochen ist was bekommen sie vom
kriegsgeschehen in anderen landesteilen
mit
vom kriegsgeschehen in anderen
landesteil nicht so sehr viel aber wir
haben heute morgen auch sirenen gehört
waren sirenen anscheinend sollen der
luftwaffenstützpunkte oder armee
stützpunkte hier um mich oder lemberg
beschossen worden seien also der krieg
war dieser stadt schon relativ nah und
wenn man wenn es wirklich so ist dass
putin und die russen dieses land
komplett unterwerfen wollen dann wird
die russische armee auch vor der stadt
lemberg nicht halt machen also im moment
herrscht noch eine trügerische ruhe aber
diese stadt
730.000 einwohner ist eine sehr große
stadt hier im westen der ukraine und
hier kann sich eigentlich niemand mehr
vorstellen dass wenn sich die russen
hier das komplette land holen wollen
dass man dann vor der stadt lemberg halt
macht also trügerische ruhe jetzt hier
noch ausländer und viele auch
europäische länder haben ja ihr
botschaftspersonal von kiew nach lemberg
verlegt ist das jetzt wirklich noch ein
sicherer ort oder muss man davon
ausgehen dass er sich vor allem viele
lemberger auch in den nächsten tagen
vielleicht sogar schon stunden auf den
fluchtweg gen westen machen im
nachbarland polen wird ja genau diese
entwicklung erwartet
wir hören von durchaus hunderten bis
tausenden menschen die sich richtung
polen auf machen wir haben selbst hier
auf den straßen einige menschen gesehen
die sich mit koffern aufgemacht hat
gerade hier vor dem hotel hat ein mann
sein auto beladen es sah so aus als
würde er die stadt relativ schnell
verlassen wollen also ich gehe davon aus
dass hier die fluchtbewegungen schon
einsetzen
den nächsten stunden vielleicht schon
aber das müssen wir haben warten im
moment werden die straßen ein bisschen
lehrer das ist unser eindruck und alles
was dann passiert das werden wir heute
abend und heute nacht noch sehen
sebastian wie verhält sich denn die
ukrainische führung ist die tatsächlich
sichtbar etwa über die medien über radio
und fernsehen man hört von ansprachen
von präsident zellen ski der unter
anderem davon spricht er die russen
wollten das ehemalige atomkraftwerk
tschernobyl erobern es gab meldungen
über den militärflugplatz in der nähe
von kiew der von russischen truppen
eingenommen worden sei zeigt die
politische führung in kiew präsenz
gegenüber der eigenen bevölkerung
was ich hier sehen kann sind vor allem
die sozialen netzwerke auf twitter dort
ist vor allem der außenminister die
metropole ba und aber auch der präsident
wolodimir selensky sehr präsent twittern
im stundentakt
öfter in der stunde nachrichten also da
zeigt sich die regierung sehr präsent
und versuchte stärke zu beweisen und dem
volk mut zu machen in der tat hatte die
ukrainische führung ja gestern auch den
ausnahmezustand für das ganze land
verhängt eine situation die dann schnell
gewissermaßen überholt wurde von der
entwicklung jetzt herrscht kriegszustand
in der ukraine was heißt das eigentlich
konkret schon gestern war die rede davon
dass etwa alle ukraine das recht haben
sollten eine waffe zu tragen was
bedeutet das kriegsrecht in der ukraine
de facto wie wirkt es sich aus
also wie sich das im einzelnen darstellt
die einzelnen punkte kann ich nicht
nennen aber es wird natürlich zur
einschränkung von freiheitsrechten
genutzt werden es soll in kiew eine
ausgangssperre geben bis 7 uhr morgens
also solche dinge werden jetzt durchaus
verhängt werden und wie haben gestern
einen jungen mann getroffen der war den
ganzen tag unterwegs um sich seinen
waffenschein erneuern zu lassen damit er
auch eine waffe tragen kann jetzt wo das
kriegsrecht verhängt wird werden
tatsächlich waffen an jeden der sie
haben will verteilt so hören wir aus
kiew die hab ich das jetzt noch nicht
gesehen aber so hören wir aus kiew und
solche dinge bewirkt dann das
kriegsrecht wenn sehen wohin diese
entwicklung vor allem auch für den
westen der ukraine führt in lemberg wo
menschen bereits größere summen bargeld
abheben wo sie sich mit lebensmitteln
und lebenswichtigen dingen eindecken
aber offenbar im moment noch davon
abstand nehmen den westen ins
nachbarland polen zu fliehen sebastian
eben danke für diese auskünfte in die
westukrainische stadt with
ja es ist ein krieg der alle europäer
besorgt ganz klar in besonderer weise
aber die westlichen nachbarn der ukraine
die polen eine
526 kilometer lange grenze verbindet die
beiden länder werden demnächst wieder
russische soldaten auf der anderen seite
stehen fragt man sich in polen besorgt
und was ist wenn diese grenze für
zehntausende vielleicht hunderttausende
ukraine zum fluchtweg nach europa wird
schon vor tagen warnte der polnische
ministerpräsident vor einem exodus aus
dem nachbarland
nichts wie raus nichts wie weg vitali
und alle kassandra haben mit ihrer
kleinen familie die ukraine am morgen
fluchtartig verlassen nun sind sie in
polen angst verzweiflung und
fassungslosigkeit
man hat mir gesagt ich sei panisch es
werde schon nichts passieren
aber nun ist es doch wahr geworden
ich kann es noch nicht fassen wir müssen
hier verlassen das ist alles was wir
noch haben
wir gehen jetzt nach polen vielleicht
später nach zypern dort haben wir
freunde da können wir bleiben bis das
schlimmste die angriffe vielleicht ein
bisschen weniger werden
viele von ihnen hier kommen aus lemberg
nur 70 kilometer von der polnischen
grenze entfernt die zukunft ungewiss in
der polnischen stadt wesel nur wenige
kilometer entfernt ruft der heutige tag
erinnerungen an 2014 wach damals hat das
ukrainische kulturzentrum geflüchtete
aus den umkämpften gebieten der ukraine
aufgenommen an die 50 menschen kann es
auch jetzt wieder unterkunft und
erstversorgung anbieten das ist der
theatersaal normalerweise finden hier
konzerte statt für flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine können wir hier die stühle
entfernen das technische equipment
abbauen und einige dutzend feldbetten
aufstellen damit die menschen sich hier
erholen können
am frühen morgen sind es noch wenige
menschen die hier am polnisch
ukrainischen grenze übergang ankommen
aber die angst sind der bevölkerung
wächst und so stellt sich polen auf eine
große zahl von geflüchteten ein menschen
wie vitali und alle kassandra und ihre
kleine familie
ja unsere polen korrespondent in
natürlich steger ist an die ukrainische
grenze gefahren nahe der stadt medica
das liegt keine 80 kilometer von lemberg
entfernt also wirklich dicht dran an der
grenze zu jenem land in dem ja krieg
herrschte natalie was ist denn die
größte sorge der menschen im osten
polens die größte sorge der menschen mit
denen sie heute sprechen konnten
tatsächlich sind wir seit heute
vormittag dann sprechen mit den menschen
immer noch kommen den ganzen tag über
gruppen familien bestimmt hunderte
alleine hier wo wir stehen die größte
sorge der menschen ist zum einen was mit
ihnen passiert wie es weitergeht aber
viele sagen wir wollen eigentlich wieder
nach hause nur wie und ob und wann und
viele sorgen sich in aller eile
liebs familien ihre angehörigen die noch
in der ukraine sind sie sind hier sie
haben es im film gesehen sie kommen mit
koffern mit nur mit dem was sie noch
schnappen konnten die grenze
aufgenommen die es gibt hier busfahrer
freiwillige die kommt die menschen
weiter transportieren privat-pkw halten
dann sagen können wir helfen wenn sie
irgendwo hin mitnehmen das sind die
sorgen die man hier hat und wie man sich
um die menschen kümmert aber es ist auch
interessant zu sehen es gibt ja sehr
viele ukraine die leben und arbeiten in
polen und da haben wir mit ukraine
angesprochen die sagen wir gehen jetzt
zurück weil wir wollen kämpfen
die leitung die satelliten leitung
natürlich ist ein bisschen instabil wir
versuchen das aber trotzdem weiter
solange es geht und sprechen vielleicht
mal über das was der polnische
innenminister heute gesagt hat nämlich
dass man sicher seit wochen auf eine
flüchtlingswelle aus der ukraine
vorbereitet wie gut ist nach dem was sie
da beobachten konnten in den vergangenen
wochen polen tatsächlich gerüstet für
eine migrationswelle die ja weit über
das hinausgehen könnte was nach 2000 14
der fall war als ja ebenfalls schon
viele ukraine vor allem auch auf der
krim und aus anderen landesteilen in
polen eine heimat gefunden haben
ich glaube das ist das entscheidende was
sie gerade man muss einfach mal abwarten
wie groß diese welle ist pläne sich um
die menschen zu kümmern und auch den
festen willen den hat polen seit wochen
die pläne
wurden jetzt raus geholt die
weltwirtschaft in die regionen hier
wurden angewiesen dass man auffanglager
eingerichtet es gibt erste anlaufpunkt
wenn sich menschen informieren man kann
ihnen weiterhelfen also der wille ist da
polen ist ja nicht dafür bekannt
auf
und helfen und die menschen hier
wirklich unbürokratisch versorgen neben
ihr vielleicht über eine sorge die polen
natürlich auch um treibt angesichts der
kriegerischen auseinandersetzungen vor
der haustür nämlich die angst vor
russland die ja immer da gewesen ist die
auch in den 1990 er jahren ja in unserem
nachbarland nie verschwunden war auch in
zeiten als russland im westen als
partner ja gar als freund betrachtet
wurde das hat sich inzwischen deutlich
geändert polnische warnungen muss man
sagen sind längst erhöht und tatsächlich
haben auch die usa tausende soldaten
nach polen verlegt ausdrücklich auf
bitten der regierung in warschau was
erwartet die regierung in warschau jetzt
speziell von der nato aber vielleicht
auch von der europäischen union die
heute abend um 20 uhr in einem weiteren
gipfeltreffen zusammenkommen wird
nun was kann man erwarten sanktionen
sind versprochen sind innen sind gesagt
aber polen erwartet vor allem dass die
nato jetzt die ostflanke noch stärker
stärkt man setzt auf abschreckung
im grunde hat man immer sehr skeptisch
zum russen zum russischen nachbarn
geblickt russland ist der ewige feind da
gab es nie groß vertrauen man muss aber
sagen dass in den letzten jahren man
sicherlich nicht damit gerechnet hat
dass ein nato land wie polen oder wie
die baltischen länder dass sie
angegriffen werden von russland aber
jetzt geht der polnische premierminister
hat heute noch einmal gesagt polen sei
ein sicheres land derzeit
rechtlich wie sie gesagt haben die
warnungen sind jetzt schärfer geworden
auch wenn man nicht wirklich daran
glauben will dass ein nato stadt
angegriffen werden kann
denn schon fragt über jahre hinweg mir
immer wieder gesagt haben wir sind noch
in der nato ist doch alles super ja die
russen sind gefährlich aber uns geht es
gut da kann sich die töne wenn man mit
leuten spricht auch im bald
soweit die leicht gestörte einschätzung
unserer polen korrespondent in natalie
steger vielleicht wird die leitungen in
den nächsten stunden wieder ein bisschen
sich stabilisieren ein zwar in vielen
dank für diese eindrücke aus medica an
der polnisch ukrainischen grenze
ja nun also hat einen krieg begonnen den
zwar die nato ja nicht unmittelbar
verwickelt ist der das bündnis aber
fordert wie vielleicht noch nie seit
seiner gründung im jahre
1949 schon in den vergangenen wochen
hatte die allianz ihre ostflanke vor
allem polen rumänien die baltischen
staaten mit zusätzlichen soldaten
verstärkt denn groß ist die angst der
östlichen mitglieder dass putins
imperiale streben auch sie bedrohen
könnte entsprechend haben heute einige
von ihnen den artikel 4 des nordatlantik
vertrages aktiviert und eine
dringlichkeitssitzung beantragt über die
ergebnisse berichtet florian a
und dass sie als trio auftreten passiert
eher selten am tag des russischen
angriffs aber scheint es nötig
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen und eu-ratspräsident michelle
haben eine gemeinsame botschaft an
russland und die welt
barisch wir verurteilen das aufs
äußerste wir befinden uns in einem
ernsten moment für europas sicherheit
nicht nur um den bombast nicht nur um
die ukraine es geht hier um die
stabilität von europa der welt und
unsere friedensordnung
national oder ice ohne die nato
aktiviert ihren verteidigungs plan für
osteuropa heißt sie verlegt weitere
truppen in die östlichen mitgliedstaaten
zur verteidigung ein eingreifen in der
ukraine nicht mitglied der nato schließt
die allianz aber aus derweil kündigt die
eu weitere sanktionen gegen russland an
am abend dazu ein sondergipfel der
staats- und regierungschefs in brüssel
die eu
und ihre mitgliedstaaten werden
gemeinsam mit ihren verbündeten russland
zur rechenschaft ziehen auf dem gipfel
werden wir uns im grundsatz auf ein
neues paket von massiven und gezielten
sanktionen einigen
testcenter die sessions im gespräch etwa
das einfrieren von russischen vermögen
in der eu oder ein exportverbot von
schlüsseltechnologien etwa in der luft
und raumfahrt
diese sanktionen werden der aggressionen
russlands gegenüber angemessen sein und
wir werden militärisch wirtschaftlich
oder im bereich der energie keine
schwäche zeigen
keine schwäche zeigen dass so die
kommissionspräsidentin gelte auch wenn
menschen vor dem krieg nach europa
fliehen
wir hoffen dass es so wenige flüchtlinge
wie möglich geben wird aber wir sind
vorbereitet und sie sind willkommen
europa hatte wochen lang zeit sich auf
eine solche eskalation einzustellen
offenbar so wirkt es heute hat man die
zeit genutzt
ja und zur stunde zur minute gibt es
auch immer mehr meldungen aus kiew
selbst so bestätigt und berichtet der
persönliche berater von präsident
zielinski dass russische truppen dem
militärflugplatz haus thurn offenbar in
der nähe von tier von dem ist vorhin
schon die rede gewesen nun also
eingenommen haben das militärische
geschehen der vormarsch der russischen
streitkräfte geht also voran thema für
unseren studiogast egon ramms
bundeswehr-general des heeres ade ich
grüße sie ganz herzlich schön wo der
unterschied wenn wir tatsächlich einmal
anfangen mit der militärischen situation
die sich natürlich von außen betrachtet
sehr schwer nur einschätzen lässt wo wir
auf unterschiedliche quellen angewiesen
sind sie sich nicht wirklich einordnen
lassen können sie aus dem was man zur
stunde beobachten kann wie russische
truppen von verschiedenen flanken aus in
die ukraine eindringen können sie als
general erkennen worauf es putin an legt
also offensichtlich schon sein erster
strategisches ziel zu sein kiew
einzunehmen und da wird im prinzip die
ukrainische regierung auszuheben wir ja
und diversen ansprachen als verbrecher
bezeichnet hat um auf diese art und
weise tief in die hand zu kriegen und
damit praktisch seine macht dann weiter
auf die ganze ukraine auszudehnen sowie
die kräfte aufgestellt waren der russen
muss man feststellen dass offensichtlich
er die absicht hat die ganze ukraine zu
erobern und dann mit der ukraine ich sag
das mal vorsichtig da die regierung zu
vertreiben und br will ja eine
entmilitarisierte zone aufbauen sondern
sache die muss man abwarten aber das
tatsächlich tut oder ob er wie in
transnistrien oder in südossetien unter
anderen bereichen die er früher georgien
krieg beispielsweise eingenommen hat
dann die tropensonne durchsteht listen
putin tatsächlich angekündigt dass er
ist offenbar tatsächlich auf eine
entwaffnung der ukraine anlegte hat aber
gleichzeitig auch die ukrainischen
streitkräfte aufgerufen die waffen
niederzulegen
wie könnte denn so etwas in der praxis
aussehen eine entwaffnung eine
demilitarisierung der ukraine das wird
ja nicht ohne den entschlossenen
widerstand
geschehen können also ich rechne nicht
damit dass ihm das gelingt das macht
seine absicht sein weil das die
vorgehensweise für seine eigenen truppen
wahnsinnig erleichtern würde die
russischen truppen wenn sie vor
maschinen könnten die ukrainische
truppen auffordern ich sag mal die weiße
fahne zu hissen und die waffen
niederzulegen aber aufgrund der
meinungsumfragen in der bevölkerung und
aufgrund des verhaltens der ukrainische
streitkräfte in den letzten wochen fast
monaten möchte ich sagen dass
demokratische streitkräfte nach meiner
erkenntnis eine ausgesprochen hohe moral
haben und von daher rechne ich mit
dieser waffen niederlegung rechne ich
nicht sondern sie werden sich
verteidigen sobald die russen die
ukraine ja auch in den wochen davor
regelrecht umzingelt eingekesselt haben
von allen seiten von norden von belarus
vom schwarzen meer her von der östlichen
seite her sowieso
welche widerstandskraft oder anders
gefragt wie groß glauben sie ist
überhaupt die widerstandskraft der
ukrainischen streitkräfte hat die
tatsächlich dieser 200.000 mann starke
armada irgend etwas entgegenzusetzen
also die ukrainische streitkräfte als
ganzes sind stärker als diese 200.000
mann man bemüht sich jetzt zur zeit auch
reservisten einzuziehen und die
reservisten entsprechen mit einzusetzen
wenn auch zunächst mal nur zu sondern
hat gesagt meine heimat verteidigung mit
nachgeordneten aufgaben
dieses die ausrüstung der ukrainischen
streitkräfte dieser
2014 deutlich verbesserte ausbildung der
ukrainischen streitkräfte geben mir noch
ein bisschen hoffnung dass die lokalen
noch eine chance hat sich zu verteidigen
man muss da war ja auch feststellen dass
der kräfteansatz den putin gewählt hat
in russland gewählt hat im prinzip aus
allen vier himmelsrichtungen ein sehr
geschickter ansatz ist weil er damit die
ukrainische streitkräfte auch in
bestimmten bereichen beschäftigen kann
und gleichzeitig sich aus seinem
vermutlichen schwerpunkt stoß auf kiew
konzentrieren welche ukrainischen
teilstreitkräfte hätten da noch die
größten chancen ist tatsächlich mit
ihren russischen feinden sag ich mal
aufzunehmen die luftwaffe scheint ja so
gut wie nicht vorhanden zu sein also die
luftwaffe dem ich an heute morgen auch
durch die durch die angriffe auf die
flughäfen es vermutlich bereits stark
getroffen und verfügt wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr überall zu viele flugzeuge
das macht die kriegführung auch für das
heer für die bodentruppen deutlich
schwieriger weil sie auch kein ich sag
mal schutzschild aus der luft haben
sondern sie sind dann möglicherweise
auch den luftangriffen russische
flugzeuge ausgesetzt dennoch glaube ich
dass der schwerpunkt der verteidigung
bei den eros soldaten liegen wird und
wie gesagt sie haben eine gute moral die
haben sie auch in den letzten wochen und
monaten bekundet und dieses ein kreis
und der ukraine hat ja bereits im
februar des jahres 2021 begonnen damals
wurden die ersten kräfte in den osten
der ukraine oder an die ukrainische
grenze im osten verlegt und jetzt dann
immer weiter aufgebaut worden bis hin zu
den verlegungen nord bildung ist aus
anderen kriegerischen konflikten wissen
wir dass solche zunächst einmal mit
luftangriffen auf strategisch wichtige
ziele beginnen gefolgt von artillerie
und daneben der infanterie die mit
panzern vorrückt auch über die grenzen
rückt wann sie persönlich überrascht
darüber dass russland quasi schon am
ersten kriegstag tatsächlich auch mit
panzern die ukrainischen grenze
überquert nein das halte ich eigentlich
sollte ich mal von den einsatz
grundsätzen jeder land streitmacht für
einen normalen ansatz also wenn ich in
ein anderes land reingehe wenn ich
angreife dann gehe ich von vornherein
mit vorbereiten wie vor da rein und gehe
vom vorjahr mit panzern da rein um
möglichst wenig eigene soldaten bei
einem solchen angriff zu anfang einer
solchen hitze zu verlieren
verlieren wir noch ein wort general
ramms über die zivilbevölkerung von der
wir auch nicht viel wissen man führt
vereinzelt von toten und verletzten vor
allem die fia bei kämpfen im osten und
süden des landes ums leben gekommen sind
beziehungsweise getötet wurden weite
teile das süd der südlichen ukraine
scheint inzwischen auch in russischer
hand zu sein glauben sie den
versicherungen moskaus dass die
zivilbevölkerung gerade in den großen
städten nicht zu befürchten hat war in
diesen versicherungen glaube ich nicht
weil in dem augenblick wurden
irgendeinem bereich auch durch die
streitkräfte vielleicht sogar durch die
bevölkerung widerstand geleistet wird
die russischen soldaten wahrscheinlich
mit aller härte versuchen werden sich
durchzusetzen und dann ist der schutz
der zivilbevölkerung in einer solchen
situation zweitrangig das wird
vermutlich so sein und neben der
wahrheit die im krieg zuerst stirbt und
das eben vor allem auch die zivilisten
die massiv erleiden werden auch dass ein
aspekte dabei ja ein erläuterungen der
strategischen militärischen
vorgehensweise nicht vergessen werden
darf wirklich general ramms ich danke
ihnen für diesen moment hier im studium
gerne
der bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat den
krieg ja gerade als putins krieg
bezeichnet doch er betrifft nicht nur
die ukraine oder europa er betrifft
möglicherweise auch die gesamte
weltordnung russlands präsident hat sich
offenbar bei seinem vorgehen abgesichert
und zwar bei einer anderen großmacht
namens china russland und china haben
mit den usa einen erklärtermaßen
gemeinsamen gegner und haben erst
kürzlich eine entsprechende allianz
besiegelt
im un-sicherheitsrat tritt china bisher
als mahner auf der botschafter fordert
eine diplomatische lösung der krise
alle seiten müssen sich in zurückhaltung
üben und aktionen vermeiden die die
spannungen anheizen
doch aus peking kommen andere töne das
chinesische außenministerium warf der
nato gestern vor der eigentliche
aggressor zu sein im internet wird die
sprecherin zitiert die nato habe
vereinbarungen mit russland über die
ost-erweiterung fünf mal gebrochen
westliche medien nennen die operation
eine invasion ich weiß nicht welche
worte sie genutzt haben als die usa
einseitige militäraktionen tech in
afghanistan dem irak unternehmen
china stellt sich somit offen auf
russland seite hält dem russischen
präsidenten den rücken frei vor drei
wochen hatten sich putin und chinas
präsident hu zu beginn der olympischen
winterspiele getroffen demonstrativ eine
strategische allianz besiegelt und
gefordert dass die nato keine weiteren
mitglieder aufnimmt der auftritt offen
provokativ gegen die nato und usa
diese allianz basiert auf gemeinsamen
werten und ideologien gemeinsamen
politischen und regierungssysteme und
die beiden staatschefs haben ähnliche
internationale ansichten und ihre
persönliche beziehung die chemie
zwischen den beiden hat eine wichtige
rolle gespielt diese bilaterale
beziehung voranzutreiben
putin und zwei autokraten die jegliche
opposition in ihren ländern brutal
unterdrücken und massive
menschenrechtsverletzungen zu
verantworten haben und offenbar eine
neue weltordnung anstreben seit einigen
jahren haben sie ihre zusammenarbeit
verstärkt militärische wirtschaftlich
finanziell und mit den usa haben beide
einen gemeinsamen gegner
beide putin und sie betrachten den
westen als gespalten und schwach und im
niedergang die welt verliert den führer
das waren die worte die sie in einer
erklärung im februar verwendet haben die
derzeitige weltordnung bröckelt sie ist
im niedergang und es braucht einen neuen
führer so ihre meinungen
putin und hier mit seinem krieg testet
russlands präsident auch diese allianz
wie eng sich die chinesen an ihn binden
werden hängt auch von der geschlossenen
reaktion des westens ab
und von china aus schauen wir jetzt über
den pazifik natürlich richten sich auch
die augen der chinesin auf den
mächtigsten mann der welt auf
us-präsident beiden der na ja nicht ganz
so mächtig war jedenfalls die russen von
einem angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
abzuhalten mrt wissen ist uns wieder aus
washington zugeschaltet live immer was
hört man heute im laufe des tages ist
aus dem weißen haus in washington ist es
jetzt erst etwa mittags hat der
präsident schon reagiert und was hat er
gesagt
ja zunächst einmal natürlich gesagt dass
dieser krieg eine aggression sei dass
putin daran schuld sei am tod und an der
zerstörungen dass die welt ihn dafür zur
verantwortung ziehen wird aber die
sanktionen auf die alle warten die
werden wohl etwa in der nächsten stunde
verkündet werden hierdurch joe biden das
ist noch einmal ein bisschen verschoben
worden wahrscheinlich weil man sich noch
einmal ein genaueres bild machen will
über die militärische lage am boden es
ist eigentlich ganz faszinierend dass
eine zweite sorge die beiden
administrationen gerade umtreibt denn
man hat eigentlich gedacht für die
nächsten jahre wäre der große gegner
china wie vorhin angesprochen und
gezeigt dass man sich ganz auf dieses
china konzentrieren wollte die beiden
administration hat erst vor zwei wochen
eine indopazifik strategie herausgegeben
aus der sehr klar heraus hervorgeht dass
china der gegner wahrscheinlich sogar
der feind der zukunft ist oder kommt ein
wladimir putin daher lässt die
truppenaufmarsch ihren und lässt im
grunde genommen ein drehbuch abrollen
was genau so von den amerikanern im
indopazifik befürchtet wird eben weil
china in den letzten monaten ja massiv
schon die militärischen provokationen
erhöht hat was taiwan angeht und
möglicherweise mit dem gedanken spielt
analogie zur ukraine in den nächsten
jahren dann auch in taiwan
einzumarschieren das heißt der doch
wieder alte neue gegner washington's
könnte doch wieder den kalten krieges
zeiten russland heißen und nicht in
china wie das ja auch unter donald trump
schon sehr fokussiert worden ist und von
seinem nachfolger joe biden mit
übernommen was könnte das für die
amerikanische außenpolitik der nächsten
jahre dauern von oder bedeuten von der
man ja immer gesagt hat dass sich der
blick weg von europa hin in den info
pazifischen raum entwickeln würde
ja die wahrheit es ist eben nicht der
alte gegner nur wieder russland und
china nicht sondern im gegenteil es sind
beide und mit ihnen möglicherweise
andere autoritäre regime rund um den
erdball joe biden hat ja seit seinem
amtsantritt immer wieder gesagt er sieht
die welt in einer großen
auseinandersetzung zwischen
autoritarismus und liberaler demokratie
und der autoritarismus aller ski und
beiden versucht derzeit die roten linien
an jeder ecke zu verschieben china hat
das in hongkong getan wird es in taiwan
versuchen und die usa glauben dass man
nicht allein durch militärische stärke
und nicht allein durch bündnisse sondern
auch durch eigene stärke
tatsächlich dieser herausforderung die
stirn bieten kann und deswegen glauben
die amerikaner dass die europäer dass
auch die amerikaner selber sehr gut
beraten sind zuschauen wie können sie
sich wirtschaftlich unabhängiger machen
von china wie können sich
wettbewerbsfähiger machen und was das
unabhängige angeht ist ja russland eben
auch ein paradebeispiel
die amerikaner hoffen dass diese krise
anders ist auch für europa sich von gas-
und öllieferungen aus russland ein für
alle mal unabhängig zu machen andere
quellen zu finden andere abnehmer der
andere lieferanten zu finden
möglicherweise auch die usa weil man
eben sie dass die autoritären regime
bereit sind diese hebel zu nutzen um
ihre interessen voranzutreiben
also ein kriegerischer konflikte der
ukraine der auch die amerikanische
außenpolitik mit implikationen belegte
jetzt noch in voller gänze gar nicht
absehbar sind immer danke für diese
einschätzungen nach washington ja fast
77 jahre nach dem ende des zweiten
weltkriegs wird also ein unabhängiger
staat von seinem nachbarn angegriffen ja
überfallen und das mit einer begründung
putins tian noch dunklere zeiten
erinnert gert anhalt fast einmal
zusammen was zur stunde an verlässlichen
bildern und informationen verfügbar ist
wie ein unwetter am östlichen horizont
zieht der krieg hinter der stadt charkiw
auf 40 kilometer vor der russischen
grenze
ungläubig und verwirrt die reaktionen
der augenzeugen was war das wo kam das
heer
und bald befinden sich die bewohner der
millionenstadt mitten im krieg
das war der schlimmste sonnenaufgang
meines lebens erklärt die junge frau ich
wachte um 5 uhr auf wald geschossen
wurde rannte auf dem balkon und da wurde
mir klar das war kein feuerwerk
da stieg schon unweit von hartz iv eine
rauchsäule über dem luftwaffenstützpunkt
schuf auf den die russen gleich unter
feuer nahmen um die luftabwehr
auszuschalten
und selbst 800 kilometer westlich der
hauptstadt kiew begann der tag mit
sirenengeheul und der ukrainische
präsident sprach in einer offenbar
hastig aufgezeichneten smartphone
botschaft zum volk
explosionen werden aus vielen städten
der ukraine gemeldet wir führen hier mit
das kriegsrecht ein vor einer minute
habe ich mit präsident beiden gesprochen
die amerikaner bemühen sich um
internationale unterstützung wie drin
während von der krim her die ersten
militärkonvois richtung westen rollen
warten auf der seit 2014 besetzten
halbinsel noch weitere kilometerlangen
konvois auf den marschbefehl
ihre angriffe gelten nur militärischen
zielen behaupten die russischen
strategen aber die ersten bilder aus der
ost ukraine zeigen nicht nur zerstörte
infrastruktur
hierbei soll es sich um den flughafen
von mario pohl handeln sondern auch
getroffene wohnanlagen der ukrainische
verteidigungsminister rief alle
einsatzfähigen landsleute auf sich bei
der truppe zu melden
jeder der eine waffe halten kann soll
sich bei den streitkräften einfinden wir
haben das verfahren vereinfacht jedem
patrioten der seinen pass vorzeigt wird
ein gewehr ausgehändigt
schon morgens bricht in kiew der verkehr
zusammen als habe die ganze stadt nur
noch ein ziel schnell weg von hier in
sicherheit
jedoch sind die straßen verstopft und
die mitfahrgelegenheiten sind rar
taxiunternehmen und fahrdienste kaum zu
erreichen und komplett ausgebucht die
preise haben sich über nacht
vervielfacht groß ist der andrang an den
bushaltestellen
ich will zu meinen eltern die wohnen auf
dem lande da ist es sicherer
auf dem luftweg gibt es jedenfalls kein
entkommen der flughafen ist lahmgelegt
auch hier wurde am morgen geschützfeuer
vernommen und den luftraum über der
ukraine meiden die meisten fluglinien
schon seit tagen
unser flug wurde wegen des
kriegsausbruchs abgesagt und nun erklärt
uns keiner was passiert und was wir tun
sollen keiner gibt uns eine antwort wie
es nun weitergehen soll
die hauptstädter sollen sich in den
bunkeranlagen aus der zeit des kalten
krieges in sicherheit bringen die
stahltüren und der dicke beton sollen
artilleriebeschuss und luftangriffen
standhalten
alle bürger sind informiert über die
zugänge zu unseren schutzräumen und
können dort zuflucht suchen wer nicht in
der kritischen infrastruktur arbeitet
der soll zu hause bleiben und sich
bereithalten verfolgen sie die
nachrichten und bleiben sie ruhig
dass die angst vor einem angriff der
drei millionen metropole nicht
unbegründet ist bewies einen
raketenanschlag der die anwohner einer
geschäftsstraße im süden der stadt am
vormittag aufschreckte gezielter
beschuss oder ein irrläufer
es gab keinen rauch und auch keinen
geruch ich wusste nicht was passiert ist
ich bin fassungslos da waren doch auch
passanten mit einkaufstaschen und kinder
unterwegs
bevor er den befehl zum angriff auf die
ukraine gab legte kremlchef putin
gestern noch einen kranz am grab des
unbekannten soldaten nieder es war der
sogenannte tag der vaterland beschützer
und als dieser tag zu ende ging setzte
der präsident seine armeen in bewegung
unsere landsleute in der ost ukraine
sind seit acht jahren der folter und dem
völkermord des regimes in kiew
ausgesetzt unser ziel ist nicht die
besetzung der ukraine sondern nur ihre
entnazifizierung und entmilitarisierung
behauptet er
und an die adresse des westens dem er am
vergangenen wochenende mit einem großen
raketen manöver zeigte wie ernst es ihm
ist hatte er gestern auch noch eine
warnung
sollte sich jemand einmischen wollen und
uns gabe drohen dann wird unsere antwort
unmittelbar erfolgen und zu konsequenzen
führen die einmalig sind in der
geschichte
als dann am nachmittag die ersten
feindlichen hubschrauber über kiew
kreisten waren bereits über 200 angriffe
der russen gemeldet worden aus dem
ganzen land
selbst ganz im westen dem alten lemberg
nahe der polnischen grenze treiben angst
und unsicherheit die menschen zu den
geldautomaten
manche wollen ihr erspartes retten
andere brauchen es für die flucht
ja und verantwortlich für diese flucht
die diesen menschen womöglich bevorsteht
ist der russische präsident der bildlich
gesprochen den dunklen anzug des
politikers gegen die uniform eines
kriegsherren getauscht hat heute früh um
6 uhr moskauer zeit hat sich wladimir
putin zu wort gemeldet mit einer rede an
die nation und das war faktisch eine
kriegserklärung an die ukraine und auch
eine offen feindselige botschaft an den
westen für begann unsere
chefkorrespondentin studienleiterin
moskau hat sich diese rede auch angehört
womit hat putin diesen einmarsch im
nachbarland begründet
also er hat im grunde genommen drei
argumentationslinien verfolgt das erste
war das was wir in den letzten wochen
und monaten schon oft gehört haben
nämlich dass die nato osterweiterung
dazu geführt habe dass die nato nun also
die russe zu nahe an die russischen
grenzen
herangerückt sei präsident putin
versucht dadurch ein bedrohungsszenario
für russland zu konstruieren punkt zwei
seiner argumentation war der das im don
was in den innerhalb der selbsternannten
volksrepublik von lohans grundton jetzt
ein völkermord stattfindet durch das
ukrainische durch die ukrainische
regierung da muss man ganz klar sagen
dass es eine falschaussage diesen
völkermord gibt es nicht und dritter
punkt seine argumentation ist also dass
die ukraine entnazifiziert werden müsse
was er damit meint da kann man auch nur
spekulieren
denn die regierung in kiew die ist
demokratisch gewählt worden
wenn also ganz gut vielleicht noch dass
ich das russische
verteidigungsminister
spricht weiter
ganz interessant ist dass das russische
verteidigungsministerium sich innerhalb
der letzten stunde noch zu wort gemeldet
hat und verkündet hat man habe das was
man sich für den heutigen donnerstag
vorgenommen habe erreicht es seien über
80 ziele in der ukraine
entweder vernichtet oder eingenommen
wurden putin-sprecher auffälligerweise
dicht von krieg sondern von einer sonder
militär operation quasi zur befreiung
der ukraine du hast das gerade
beschrieben wie groß ist die zustimmung
zu dieser invasion in der russischen
bevölkerung lässt sich das irgendwie
messen demographie wie in westlichen
ländern zumindest unbeeinflusst da gibt
es ja vermutlich nicht
ja so unabhängige umfragen habe ich im
moment noch nicht gesehen wir haben uns
heute nachmittag selber mal auf moskaus
straßen um gehört dass es natürlich in
keiner weise repräsentativ aber eben
doch ganz interessant denn da ist
deutliche
generationenwechsel sozusagen zu sehen
die älteren russinnen die wir befragt
haben die waren eher auf putins linie
und haben teilweise fast wortwörtlich
teile seiner rede wieder gegeben wenn
die sie nach ihrer haltung gefragt haben
das sind vor allem die menschen die sich
dann eben aus den staatlichen fernsehen
informieren unter den jüngeren russinnen
und russen da war deutlich mehr krieg
skepsis zu hören es hat auch hier in
moskau heute abend den versuch gegeben
eine anti kriegs demonstration zu
starten allerdings hat die polizei den
platz der dafür vorgesehen war schon
abgesperrt bevor die demonstranten
überhaupt gekommen sind und insofern
dass quasi verhindert auch da haben sich
aber dann eher die jüngeren russinnen
und russen eingefunden und die mit denen
wir da gesprochen haben die wiederum
haben teilweise sagt sie schämen sich
für das was ihr präsident da wie er
gerade militärisch gegen die ukraine vor
geht also an durchaus durchwachsen das
meinungsbild auf den straßen der
russischen hauptstadt das aber den
kriegspfad den kurs den präsidenten
putin eingeschlagen hat sicherlich nicht
verändern wird für begann danke für
diese einschätzungen nach moskau
der liebe zuschauern und zuschauer das
war ja das spezial an einem tag der so
viele bilder produziert ja so viele
stimmen produziert hat und einen am ende
doch sprachlos zurücklässt fast 80 jahre
nach ende des zweiten weltkriegs
herrscht wie der krieg in europa ein
krieg der wohl mehr verändern wird als
wir uns zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
vorstellen können über das weitere
kriegsgeschehen halten wir sie natürlich
weiter auf dem laufenden mit analysen
und hintergründen auch in einem weiteren
zdf spezial um 19 uhr 35 ihnen noch
einen guten abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
russische truppen sind in der ukraine
einmarschiert lass es putins krieg sagt
der deutsche bundeskanzler mehr über
diesen tag der europa schon jetzt
verändert hat gleich um 7
[Musik]
wussten sie dass sich mit jeder spieler